それではよろしくお願いします
今日はあの天皇陛下のお誕生日でございますけど
なんか全然関係ない方々も今日はお誕生日をお祝いするという協会のメンバーの方々もいらっしゃいまして
で 本当におめでとうございます
えーと 他の今日お誕生日の方々はいらっしゃいますかね
うん はい あの まあこれから楽しみがなくなると思いますけど
テーマに入ったら えーと
あの 今日のテーマは あの
体と心の連携プレーという
まあこのキャッチフレーズは一応私が作るものではございません
で 精神と肉 肉体を調和に調和させると
いうテーマで 体と心の調和ですね
まず あの まあ論文形式でいきますのでね
まず目的 これからの解説は
スマートで美しく無限まで長期で生きていられるためのアドバイスではありません
で ヨーガ実践の目標にも一致しません
で 生きる上では あの これどう読みますかね
つまづかないため 期待する目的に達するため
清らかな心を保ち 解脱の道を進めるためであります
これはっきりしますね
説明は要りませんね それから初めからの期待外れということになります
結構美しくて健康で長生きできればありがたいなと皆様人類が思ってますけどね
まあこれをまあ私たちは最初からも
まあそれをよしておきましょうという立場で話しますが
あの仏教の裏技を使えばね
まあヨーガをやってるよりもかなり体を健康で保つことはもう見事にできます
で 寿命も延ばすこともできます
不可能じゃないんです
で いろんなもう体の病気なんかはね
抑えておいて発病しないようにしてあげることもできます
そんなに大げさなことではありません
例えばね まあ今まだ治療もない
いろいろウイルスとかなんとかとかね
感染しても やっぱり発病はしないようにするとかね
そういう奇跡っぽいものはぐちゃぐちゃできます
仏教の裏技を使えば だから商売には何にもならない
あんまりにも単純なんです
問題はその方法を教えてあげないということはどういうことかと自分でも知りません
で で 仏教のね 本来の目的から見れば馬鹿馬鹿しいんですよ
まあちょっと病気を抑えてもらったと
だから何ということになるんです
で すごい まあ重病で危篤状態にいたんだけど
なんとか三宝のおかげで生き延びたと
1ヶ月ぐらい だから何と
で 私もやっぱり結構経験あるんですね
自分の国でね 人がもうそういう最後の時期になっちゃうと
まあ結構お坊さんたちを家に呼んだりはする
で だからなんか都合が悪くて
私が行くことになると
もう誰から見ても あとまあ2
3時間かなとかね 今日1日は持たないだろうと思っている人々なんですけど
私が喋ってそれなりの祝福をしたり
あの世に行く準備をしてあげたりすると
何のことなくまた 3ヶ月とかまで持ったりするんですね
だからこれでいいかと
本人はもう覚悟をしてあの世にじゃあ行きますとかね
お世話になったぞという気分でね
そのおばあちゃんがおじい様がいるのに
こちら余計なことをしちゃってね
だからこれ延命装置をつけることと同じなんですよ
だから心にはすごい力がありますよ
だからそれはどのように使えるのかというね
これまたもう他力じゃないんです
そのその人にはすごい力があるんです
そこはスイッチ入れ入れてあげるだけなんです
ですから このそういうのはあるんだけど
そんなことこの日本で言っちゃうと
もう最悪 だから皆様は科学的に
知識的に経済的には一流かもしれませんだけど
この宗教とか精神とかね
心理とか人生についてはまだまだ幼稚園ですね
だから そういうわけもわからない
知らないことはよく注意して紹介した方がいいということで
私は徹底的に理性に基づいている純正仏教しか語らないということに決めてあります
で 勝手に決めたことだから
皆様は異論がありますと言ったってもね
一応通じません もう頼まれるということは結構ありますよ
ことはあります はい そういうことで
まあ余計な話は時間ないんですけど
たくさんなります はい
まずはあの最後のポイントをまず言います
で 心っていうのは精神ですね
あまりまあ一般的に考えてください
心は優位なんですね で
体と心の関係では優位なのは心です
それは仏教の立場なんですね
肉体よりは心がとんでもない優位であると
で そう言っていて 一切の物事のリーダーは心であると説かれています
何であろうとも リーダーは親分は心ですよと
で これはこのパーリ教でチッティラニゲテーローコチッティにパーリカッせてというところでね
書かれているところで
すべては心の支配下であります
で 心は全部支配しているんだっていう
それはこのチッタセーカダンマサッビーワサマニノグというところですね
何であろうとも心の支配下です
だからこれっていうのはすごい革命的な言葉なんです
本当に皆様 そこは文字通りに読んでみると
世界で誰でもそんなことは言ってないんです
もう何でもかんでも支配している絶対的なエネルギー
パワーが心だよと 他誰が言ってます？そんなことは誰も言ってないんです
神だよ 魂だよという偉い方々はいくらでもいます
います  現代人は金だよとも言ってますね
で これ 現代人がものすごい真面目な真剣な顔をして金だよと言ったってもね
やっぱりやっぱりそれは嘘やとふざけてるだけだということをわかっているし
で 金で何でもできるということはね
まあ一応腹が立って言ってますけど
実際はできないとみんな知ってます
ですから この現代人のふざけて言ってる言葉は置いておいて
あの まあ科学的な思考ある人っていうのは何も知らないという意味ですからね
威張ってますね 何でも知ってるんだぞとね
面白いことです 科学ばっかり知ってる人って何でも知らないんです
だから もののことを知ったってのは
生きるっていうことは知ってほしいんですね
生きるとは何かと はい
そういうことで 仏教 のその言葉っていうのは
ちょっと客観的に考えてください
あまりにも怖い言葉なんです
今言ったら殺されますよ
神を冒涜したんだぞと
何言うのかと あんたもうちっぽけなろくでもない人間でいて
心が一切支配管理しているんだよと
いうのはすごい言葉なんです
はい さらに言います 創造者
最後に創造者心であると説かれるんです
いろんなことを言いますね
お釈迦様 見えますね で
マノーマヤ この創造者という言葉は
私はこのマノーマヤという言葉を翻訳するんですね
心により創造される幻想という意味もあります
すべてマノーマヤであるといわれるメイドバイザマインドということになりますね
プロダクションオブザマインド
心の産物で生産物であると
すごいことでしょ まあ単純に見れば
この椅子は誰が作ったのかといったら
バカが裏見るんですね
ラベルをね どんな会社
誰かとか これは心が作ったもんでしょ
結局は これ手足機械作らない
だから手足動くのは心でしょうに
機械作るの心でしょうに
だからこの椅子は誰が作ったのかというと心だよと
ということで まあまあそういうわかりきっていることなんですね
しかし 言いたくないのは何なのかと
わかりきったことを堂々と
はい 電気切れ で わかりきったことをね
堂々と言った方がいいんです
で 心の位に ここ用ではなくて
このようにいくつかの立場で語られているんですね
だから一体心とはといったら
お釈迦様はまあリーダーでありとかね
まあ支配してあるとかね
また 何でもかんでも心が作っているんだとか
いくつかの言葉を言っているんです
一体心の立場は何なのかと疑問も生じ
だから一体あなたは何を言っているのかと
心はどっち？とはっきりしなさいと言っても
まあまあ別にしょうがないんです
だからお釈迦様は心はこうでありと言って
また別な言葉でこうであると言って
また別な心でこうでありと言っちゃうんですね
だったら何やと なんかあの人はなんかすごいもう態度でっかいと
あの人はなんかちょっと怯えてるんだとかね
だからどちらかと聞きたくなるでしょうね
しかし この場合は このそういういくつかの言葉をちょっと並び
あるの単語を使っても
それなりの理由があるんです
で はっきりこれというふうに断言的に言っちゃうと
社会が混乱するんですね
この言葉が皆様は全然へっちゃらで聞いているんですけど
これ革命的な言葉なんです
社会を繰り替えしちゃうほどの怖い言葉なんです
まあ現代人は宗教心もね
もうほとんど薄れて薄れて薄れていきますからね
それほど危険じゃないかもしれませんだけど
いまだに現代知識では
科学でも心は勉強してないんです
思考によって人が精神的な病気になったりするところはありますけど
まあそこでちょこちょこと思考をいじるだけで
あんまり心そのものについては勉強したことはないんです
だから この当時ではかなり問題があったんだけど
この背景があったんですね
背景がまず出てくるのは
この神と霊魂という言葉なんですね
他宗教では神と霊魂という二次元がありますね
神は体と魂を創造するんですね
これ 他宗教といっても
現代までこの宗教は現役で現役で
で いろんなもう名前で同じことを教えているんですね
で イスラム教っていうもあるし
キリスト教はもうたくさん宗派があるし
で イスラム教はスンニ派とかシーア派がね
お互い殺し合いやってるし
同じ神を信仰して同じコーランを信仰してるんですけど
あの 何やってるのかさっぱりわからないんですよ
我々からはね で このシーア派とあれはモハメッドの関係があって
あるべきかないかというだけの差なんですけど
まあとにかくそういう喧嘩しながら殺し合いしながら
みんなこの神を信仰しているんですね
そこで神が人間の体も作って
魂も作ったということになるんですね
あのキリスト教のあのインチキ物語を読んでみると
まず泥で土で人間を作って
それから魂を入れるんですね
だから最初は体作ってそれから魂を入れるというね
で だからストーリーだからね
逆でもいいんじゃないかなとね
新しく聖書を書くならば
最初は神が霊魂を作って
この霊魂に体を付けてあげたんだよとと言ったっても悪くないんだけどね
で 体が魂を汚すという思考があるが
魂は体を汚すという思考はありません
この世界なる宗教ではよくへっちゃらで言うんですね
で 魂 体が魂を汚すと誘惑されると
キリスト教の場合も同じことで
イスラム教の場合で同じことで
ヒンドゥー教でもどちらでも同じことなんです
アロワソロースタ教にしても
どちらにしても 魂を体が物質が肉体が汚しちゃうという話なんです
しかし 誰も魂が体を汚すとは言わないんですね
それは大事なポイントなんです
だからね 私の魂は神様に与えてくれてありがたい
尊い この上のないすごいことやと
すごいものやと しかし
この肉体でね 肉体欲で
怒りで 欲で ああありがたい魂が汚れてるんだと
誘惑されちゃって負けてるんだと
という罪を付けているんです
体が本来汚れているのか
神は汚れた物質を作ったのかは言わないんですね
体が堂々と言うんですが
では聞きますけど 体っていうのは汚物でしょうかと
だから神様の汚物の体を作って
そこに一生懸命魂を吹っ込んでやるとかね
もう口で吹っ込んだかポンプで突っ込んだか分かりませんだけどね
もしかすると足踏みのポンプでしたでしょうね
空気入れ で なんとか使って
この泥で作った汚物で作った体に魂を吹っ込んでやったんですね
それだから魂が汚れちゃうんですね
だから馬鹿なのは人間か神かどっちかわからないんですね
人間が一生懸命いろんな修行したりしてね
もういろんなことをお祈りするは
賛美歌を歌うは もうお数珠を回すは
もう飛び上がる 音楽を演奏するは
もうしても何とかしても魂を清らかにしようかなと
無理やと思いますけどね
だって神がやっちゃったんだからね
人間にそれはリピ リコールすることできんでしょ
だからどちらの馬鹿ですかね
神ですか？人間ですかね
だから神がね 汚物の中に魂を吹き込んだならばね
神にあんたなんてことするのかと
この尊いものを汚すなよと
というべきところは逆になってますね
全部逆さまになっていますね
言い方は だからそういうふうにも私は辛口と言いますけど
私はこの論理は成り立ってないということだけ言いたいんですね
言っていることはその場で矛盾になっちゃうんです
もう言葉終わりまで言う前に
もう矛盾は成り立っているんです
それだけ言いたいんですね
理論ばっかり言っちゃうと面白くないんだから
まあまあ そういうふうに軽く言うんです
魂が体を作るというのは神への冒涜になりますね
だからこの魂がすごいことやって
魂が体を作ると言っちゃうと
それはもう神に対するひどいぶっぞい侮辱
冒涜になるんです だからお釈迦様がかなり気をつけるんですよ
全部心が作りますよと言ったら
他宗教の言葉に翻訳すると
魂が体を作るんであって
神がではなくなっちゃうんですね
だからこれすごい怖いんですね
そういうのは だから魂という単語を使ってないんだけど
お釈迦様は心という単語を使ってますけど
心が何でもかんでも創造するんだよと
要するにそれ 魂 神様の入れ替えなんですね
だから結構いろいろ条件をつけて
お釈迦様はそこら辺は人が困らないように語っているんです
で 体と霊魂ということで
神を設定しないが 体と魂が区別して存在すると説く宗教もあります
また この一神教以外 インドではね
いくつたくさん宗教がありまして
一部の宗教家は体がある
魂があると 誰が作ったとは言わないんです
この明確な二分論をデュアリズムというね
二分論を語るんですね
で この場合は魂は永遠な永遠のもので
死後も続くんですね そうやってデュアリズムで
もう二分論で魂と体があるというと
もう体はわかる わかってるんだからね
さっぱりわからないのは魂のことだからね
だからわからないものだから何でも言えるんですね
だから魂がずっと続くんだよと
体はずっと続くんだよとは言えないんですね
目の前で壊れていくんだから
だからそういう失敗しません
賢いんです  魂がずっと永続するんだと言うんです
しかし 魂は体によって汚れるんです
その人々も同じことを言っちゃうんです
魂は体によって汚れちゃうんだと
体っていうのは物質ですね
と魂が両方とも永遠で
それぞれ勝手に流れるのだという宗教はあります
またもう一つ宗教がありまして
今日はこの明確な出典は出しません
どんなどんな名前のどんなどんな宗教かとね
言ったって 皆さんは興味もないし
わかってもないし わかってなかったら教えてくれと言うかもしれませんし
教えたくたってもどうったことはないし
で もうそんなこと知らなくたってもね
結構楽に生きていられます
で 知ってる私にとっても
あんまり楽じゃないんです
そんなこと知ったんだからといって
もうどんどん悪口のレベルが上がるだけ
何も知らない場合は知らないことだから
ちょっと遠慮しますけどもね
知りすぎもよくないんです
一応そういう宗教があるんですね
物質も永遠で永続しているんだと
魂も永続しているんだと
その場合は宗教は微妙に変わっちゃうんです
だから今私が死んだら
私が死にませんね 誰かが死んじゃったら
その人の体が残ってるでしょ
それが魂が出ていってるでしょ
ということは 魂は勝手に永続している
物質は別に永続しているという
ツーサイクルス二輪が出てくるんですね
循環二つ 物質は物質の勝手で
サイクルでもう回って回って回っていく
魂は魂の勝手で回って回って回っていくと
なんか面白いんですよ
私の魂は次は誰の体に入るかわかりませんだからね
という感じになりますね
次 その場合は 魂は汚れて清らかになったり
また汚れたりして転生するんです
この最後に言った宗教では
魂は勝手にずっと回っていくんです
いろんな物体に入って入って入って
また好き勝手に様々な物体に入ったりはする
物体も自分勝手にいろんなところに入ったりする
で だけは物質はそのまま回転したってもね
汚れているか汚れていないかということは問題にしないんです
そういう人々も 魂だけはある時は汚れるが
ある時はまたきれいになる
だからどんなブッダに飛び込むかっていうことでしょう
だからすごい清らかなブッダに魂が飛び込んだら
魂がすごい清々して機嫌が良くて
例えばものすごく美しい
清らかな神とかね ものすごい高次元な肉体に体に入り込んだら
魂はきれいなんですね
しかし そこでまたもう壊れますから
またどこかに飛んでいかなくちゃいけないんですね
また変なところに入り込んじゃうと
また汚れると  子供と同じなんですね
子供はもうお母さんがもう手当しちゃうと
すごい可愛くて綺麗でかっこよくて
それでずっと一回り回ってくると
もうとんでもない 汚くて
またもうちょっとなんとか何とかもうご飯食べさせないんで
お母さん口と手だけで洗って
また服を汚れをね いくらか叩いてあげて
またご飯食べさせて また放っておくと
またいう一回り回ってくると
またもう世界中のゴミは全部体に付いてくるんですね
で そんな感じで魂も汚れたりきれいになったり
汚れたりきれいになったりで
バラバラっていうことは言ってるんです
で 転生の終わりに自動的に止まるっていうことですね
そのように魂が回転 回転
回転 回転 回転して自動的に止まると
この自動的に止まるっていうことは
その宗教の特色なんですね
この宗教は修行しなくたっていいんだと
それであちこちあちこち行って
まあプログラムが終わったら終了するんだと
それでもっとまとめて言うんですね
一つの魂に この回数券みたいにいろいろ割り当てがあるんだと
人間として何回生まれるのかと
人間に生まれてても バラモンカーストで何回生まれるのか
シャットシャトリヤカーストで何回か
ワイシュヤカーストで何回かとかね
シュードラカーストで何回かとか
この回数決まってるんだと
それで人間に生まれても
王家で何回生まれるか
王として何回生まれるのかとか
大臣として何回とかね
それから宗教家として何回かとか
宗教の中でのキリスト教じゃなかったんですけど
もうなんだらなんだら宗教で何回何回生まれるか
そんな決まってるんだと
そこで犬になる回数とか豚になる回数とかね
あって 自分の回数が終わったらもう卒業やと
そういうこの まあ自動的に目的に達する教えなんですね
オートメーションで 魂も体も死で壊れて終わるものだと説く宗教もあります
まだいるんですね 魂もありますけど
体もありますけど 壊れますよと
分解しますよと 死ぬと分解しちゃったらもう話はない
それで終わりと で それがなんか現代唯物論に何か似ていますけどね
で インドではこれに唯物論やというんですけど
本当はちょっと違う唯物論なんですね
あの  何のわけもわからない唯物論も
ソクラテス カールマルクスでしたっけ？全然勉強してないんですね
物事は で だから頭が悪ければね
時代もこの世紀のね すごい人々へと呼ぶんです
で 彼らはこの特に科学もね
唯物論に成り代わっているし
で まあそういう完成された思考じゃないんですね
ただ感想 はい それでその現代的な唯物論とは違います
また 魂にランクをつける宗教もあります
で 人の性格 生き方 知識レベル
カーストなどは魂のランクで定めるんですね
これと面白いんです で
その宗教が 魂はもうステップアップしながら
あるいはステップダウンしながら転生するんだと
皆様と同じ会社でね まあ昇格ばっかりでなく
降格もあったりしますね
あるいは何の変哲もなく 10年も仕事をするとかね
上がることも下がることもなくというね
そういうすごい嫌な存在なんですね
で で 毎年毎年 ちょっとちょっとちょっとステップアップになって
やがてあのね 取締役で終わればね
何の順調で何の問題もないんだけどね
まあ取締役で終わるどころか
もう平社員でそのままで終わっちゃう場合もあります
それと同じく 魂も上昇したらするわ
降下するわ またもう同じレベルで
またまたいろいろちょこちょこと上昇して
ドーンと落ちついたりとか
魂がそういう風にランクつけているんだと
ですから 我々人間で言ったら
すごい金持ちがいる すごい知識人がいる
すごい美人がいるとかね
ものすごい美しく歌える人がいるし
ものすごい歌手能力あるんだけど
まるっきり売れない あのね
音楽家もいたりとかね
で まるっきり歌う歌手力あるのかと
この人はと思う人もいるんだけど
売れるは売れな歌はね
きりがなく とか そうやって人間の中でもいろいろバラバラでしょうね
この宗教から見れば それ魂のランクなんですね
魂のランクでそれを定めているんです
人間が何者かということは
それでランクに色で 青い色
黒い色 黄色い色 赤い色とかね
もうピンク色とかね 色つけてるんです
メインには 7つの色につけてます
そこで その宗教家が自分たちの魂には色がないんだと
ただ光のみだと 言ってます
その宗教から見ると ブッダはすごい黒い色に入るんです
すごい低いランクなんです
ブッダの魂は お釈迦さんにくったくと言われてましたけどね
で そういうのは出店あれこれ出しちゃうとね
まあこれはもう 2年の授業になります
今日は本当はこのでっかい本 2冊ぐらいのデータがありまして
このほんのちょっとしか一番最後に言うべきことしか今日は紹介しません
で このその魂のランクは色分けしてあったの
人は魂のランクを上げるように努力修行する必要があると
だから彼が言うのは 魂はどんどんどんどん昇格するように頑張ってくださいと当たり前のことを言ってます
このような思想背景があったので
ブッダの言葉は誤解されないように注意して語られたんです
だからお釈迦様は曖昧中途半端で語ったわけではなくて
ものの見事にみんな誤解されないように
興奮しないように で しかし
理解していただけるようにゆっくりと語っていたんです
例えば大釈尊がある日はね
この世は一体絶対誰が作っているんですかと
生命はと 生命は維持管理
支配は誰がやっているんでしょうかと
お釈迦様に聞いたら お釈迦様はまあこれは心でしょうね
心だよと言うんです まあそうですかというだけで終わっちゃうんですね
何も爆破しないで 爆弾は仕掛けてますけど
お釈迦様はやがてそれ爆破してほしいんです
なかなか 2500年なんてみんなえ？という感じでね
お釈迦様 すごいこと言ってますよ
まだこの爆弾は爆破してない
だから汚れそのまんまなんです
この汚くて汚くてでっかいビルがあって
迷惑で これ綺麗さっぱり爆破して美しい公園にしたいんですが
もう全部灰になるぐらい爆弾仕掛けてありますけど
このスイッチは我々入れなくちゃいけないんですね
だから心が何でもかんでも全て自分が心だとわかっちゃうと
どれほど自由になると思いますか？一切全て我が心次第やと
どれほど自由になるのかと
どれほど人間が自己責任で生きるのかと
想像ができないんですよ
今はクリスマスと それから正月も頭がいかれているでしょうに
そんなのは全くなく 冷静で堂々といられます
だから今エレベーターでね
子供二人でサンタクロース感じで
赤いな 白いの帽子を被ったりとか
寒いじゃないかと思いますけど
なぜそんなことをやるのかと
遊びたければもういつでも遊んじゃえばいいのに
はい しかし この魂はイコール心ではありません
自分がいるという自覚がありますね
我々に それは六感の機能により認識なんです
みんなこの魂って言ってますけど
あの実感のことなんです
私がいるんだとかね この私がいるんだということは
観念的な言葉で六感がありますね
目耳鼻口とか それで感じるでしょ
目で何か見えたら見えたという感覚が生まれる
それは言葉にするんです
私が見まったと 何か耳に触れたら感じるでしょ
そうするとそれは言葉にする
私が聞きましたと それで数学的にずっと私がというコンスタントファクターが
コンスタントファクターなんて言いますか
日本語で定数が出てくるんですね
それであると勘違いするんです
あれは初めから存在しなかったこと
ファクターなんですよ
聞こえただけなんです
主語がないんです 聞こえただからね
聴覚が生まれたなんです
だから主語が聴覚にならなくちゃいけないんです
私が聞いたというんですね
それが その目次なんで
この湾曲なんです 問題は
それは単なる脳細胞がやっていることなんです
脳はそんなに鋭い 賢く鋭くはないんです
だからすごく苦労するんで
何か理解しようとすると
だから五感 六感があります
五感ではなくて ほら 六感
ただ目に何か触れると感じる
感じるとそれで終わりますけどね
それにも何か観念 概念入れちゃうの
私が見ましたと 耳で何か感じたら
それで終わりますけど
私が聞きましたと 舌で何か味を感じたら私が味わいましたということ
だから全部私が考えた
私が味わいました 私が匂いを嗅ぎました
私が体で感じたということで
私が私が私が私がということが入ってくるんですね
ですから すべて見た 感じた
全部プラス記号でまとめると
一番前に私がと ことは括弧を入れて私がということを入れられますね
だから そういう単純な概念遊びが実体論としてあると勘違いしてますね
ギリシャ哲学で どんな死に物にも模範的なものが天国にあると言っていた人がいたでしょ
あれ 誰でしたっけ？え？プラトン
プラトン うん そんな感じ
プラトニックコンセプトなんです
だから笑っちゃいますけどね
仏教は 認識は情報によって変わる
それでこの認識というものも
私が見たと言ったっても
次から次へ次から次へ次から次へと見続けているでしょうに
だから感覚が変わって変わって変わって変わっていくでしょうに
だから私がという定数は成り立たないんです
認識の流れを大雑把にまとめて自分とまた認識する
それも一つの認識なんですね
自分だと指す対象の中身は常に変わる
この働きに対して心というんです
仏教の心っていうのは
この６種類の認識の得る流れなんです
台風があると言ったっても
台風の魂とかなんとかないでしょ
ただ風があちこち回るだけで
そこであの太平洋 太平洋で台風が現れて日本上陸したっても
同じ風じゃないでしょ
海の上の風がそこで回って
隣の風が次に回って次に回ってなんですね
同じ風がずっと来ているわけでもないんです
だからそのように認識もこの６種類の台風の流れなんです
それは全部まとめて他宗教は魂というし
仏教は心というんです
他宗教は それは一定して固定して変わらないものだといい加減なことを言ってるだけ
えーと 魂とは変わらない実体なの
しかし 魂っていうのは全く変わらないものなんです
しかし それがあると実証することは不可能です
魂 魂 みんな言ってるだけで
一度でも史上実証したことはないんです
魂がある 神がいるいると
原始時代 石器時代 木から降りた時の時から言ってますけど
だからこのヒモの椅子というかね
あの半分猿の人間もね
神がいると思っていたんだからね
そんなすごい考え方じゃないんでしょ
絶対的な神がいるっていうことは
現代人には到底理解も行き届かないぐらいすごい思考であると
なんだこれ もう石器時代にね
洞窟の中でもね 木から降りたばっかりのあの半分のね
人間もね ヒモの椅子の方々もね
思っていたんだから ブッダがおっしゃっているように
かなり研究して 徹底的に調べて発見したものじゃないでしょうに
だから実証したことはないんですね
実証できないが それこそ本物の存在だというのは
あの爆笑のためにしかなんでもないんです
だから魂がある 神様がいると言ったら
もうお腹を抱えて笑った方がいいんですよ
笑うところをおびえるんだから
私は楽しいんですよ 今頃新宿とかあちこち行くとね
なんか棒のスティックの前にスピーカーをつけて
汝は神を信じますか？とか
楽しくてたまらないですね
だってすぐちょっとまた四方四十歩歩いたら
あの何元でしたっけ？えっ
藤本 なんとかでありますけどね
そちらに五百円 百円払う
千円払う必要ないんですよ
そちらは若者たちがとって呼ばれたこと
あの 今我々やってますけどね
あの来てくだせませんかとかね
ちょっと忙しいんだからすいませんとということでね
そう行かなくても あの前に行ったら
みんなあれほど笑うものあるんですかね
だって 試しにあの人たちってあんた本当に知ってる？と聞いてみてください
知ってる？あの今日こそも知らないんだからね
信じてないんです ただ信仰するだけ
とにかく証拠実証は絶対できないんだからこそ存在するんだろうという
あの教理 あの神理学者
神 何かしら神学者たちのね
言葉っていうのはね もう本当におかしいんです
他宗教の魂霊魂の概念を仏教心という概念に変えたのではありません
ただ ブッダが皆様方は魂
魂と言っている言葉に別な言葉を入れちゃってごまかったわけじゃないんです
で ブッダがもう本当に調べて
本当に調べて やっぱり心だよと
すべて支配しているのはと発見して語ったんです
ですから 宗教の単語の入れ替えだけではないんです
で 魂信じちゃうと問題はたくさん出てくるんですね
実証できないから存在するということですね
実証できないから存在すると言えるんですかね
永遠不滅の魂であるならば
汚れることも清らかになることもあり得ないんです
永遠不滅の魂が汚れないでしょ
汚れたら変化したことになっちゃうんだから
汚れた魂を何か洗っておいたってまた汚れるんだから
意味がないでしょうね
子供と同じなんですね
洗っても全然意味がないんです
だから本人たちが言うことはその場の矛盾なんです
魂が汚れましたから 頑張って綺麗にしましょうと
はいはい 頑張ってください
また汚れますよと だって永遠不滅の魂は汚れるはずも発想はもともとないんだから
一時的に汚れるというならば
清らかにしてもうそれも一時的でしょうに
体には魂に影響を与えることができると思うなら
体が魂より偉い また 次の矛盾というのは
この魂はね 本来清潔で清らかで至福なんですけど
肉体によって汚れているんだと
これはジャイナ教やキリスト教やらみんなそう思っているんです
こんな絶対的存在 ジャイナ教だったら千智千能の力を持ってる魂が
こんなちっぽけな体で汚れるでしょ
ということは 誰が偉いんですかね
肉体が偉いんです 魂が偉くないでしょう
だからそこ矛盾でしょ
偉い偉いというならば汚れると言うんだから
だったら違うでしょ 偉いのは汚したやつでしょ
まあ例えば あの割れないガラス作りでしょ
だって結構強化ガラスありますね
まあ相当強いでしょ それで会社が自慢する
我々はもうもう 1トンの衝撃にも割れない強化ガラスを作ったよと
それである人がああそうと言って
手にぶん殴っちゃう パンチ一つやっちゃう
そのパンチで割れたならば
誰が偉い？あの強化ガラスないでしょう
この人に力がありすぎでしょう
まあ最近のね あのインフルエンザには今ワクチンを打ってるでしょ
で ワクチンを打っても
もしインフルエンザにかかったら
どちらが強いんですかね
ウイルス ワクチン 決まってるでしょう
ウイルスの方が勝ったんだから
だから魂と体の関係で体が魂を汚すのであれば
えらいの体が肉体なんです
それであの人々の哲学はそこでね
何の意味なくなっちゃうんですね
で 体と心の相互依存の関係は語れないんです
だから体と心っていうのは結構お互い様
依存し合ってるんだという現実的な話は言えなくなりますが
皆様はヨーガやってますね
むちゃくちゃなこと言ってますよ
そのヒンドゥー教で なのにヨーガの先生がもうこれポーズ
このポーズすれば魂が綺麗になるんだと
私はよく分かりますよ
足一歩上げていると 逆立ちしていると
どうやって魂が綺麗になるのかと
それで菜食主義でもあるでしょうに
それで魂が綺麗になるんですかね
食ったものでどこでも魂ですね
もし菜食主義はいいんだけど
食べたものがちょっと腐っていたら
あ かわいそうに 魂もね
腐ってしまいます だからこの笑い話でしょうね
健康にいいんだから 菜食主義になるのは私も大賛成
脂肪ばっかしでね コレステロールなんか食うなよと
それって単純な論理的なことであって
野菜食いなさいと 緑のものとかね
あれはものすごく美味しいんだよと
それで魂が綺麗になると思ったらね
もうちょっと もうこれは冗談ですね